bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue voici
les titres de votre journal au moins 45
morts dont 29 en vendée la tempête de la
nuit dernière a été meurtrière et
dévastatrice
plus de huit cent mille foyers sont
encore privés d'électricité
le gouvernement débloque un million
d'euros d'aidé d'urgence au chili les
secours s'organisent 24 heures après le
séisme la ville de concepcion proche de
l'épicentre est victime des pillards
depuis ce matin le tremblement de terre
a fait plus de 700 morts
la campagne des régionales pourtant loin
derrière le parti socialiste europe
écologie affirme pouvoir bousculer le
scrutin dans plusieurs régions notamment
en poitou charentes nous demanderons à
la tête de liste cécile duflot d'où lui
vient cette confiance la secrétaire
nationale des verts est notre invité
bonsoir à tout à l'heure
les jo de vancouver derniers coups de
patins ce soir la france repartir avec
11 médailles
retour sur les meilleurs moments de la
quinzaine et puis neuf césars pour un
seul film 2 pour un seul homme
un prophète de jacques audiard est le
grand vainqueur son interprète principal
a remporté les prix du meilleur espoir
et meilleur acteur c'est une première
tahar rahim est notre invité merci
d'être là tout à l'heure mais d'abord
c'est l'image du jour là avant dé
dévastée par les intempéries regarder et
la rupture d'une digue à l'aiguillon sur
mer qui a entraîné une montée des eaux
rapide et imprévisible des dizaines de
personnes ont été surprises dans leur
sommeil à l'aube des images de chaos au
moins 29 morts
vous le disais en titre pour ce seul
département au moins 45 voire 50 au
total la tempête xynthia est la plus
destructrice depuis celle de 99 qui
avait fait 92 morts
la vendée est donc le département le
plus violemment touchés par cette
tempête
avec deux villages qui sont ce soir en
partie submergée gérard griesbeck karine
comazzi euan burton
la vendée est ce soir une région
sinistrée vision de désolation la
tempête n'a épargné personne
on compte les blessés par dizaines mais
aussi les morts dans le village de
l'aiguillon sur mer
une digue a cédé les regarde et on a
plus de vélo il ya plus retenu la digue
l'aele et koupèla et là maintenant bel
olo de mer va rentrer dans l'ailé dans
les habitations
toute la journée des maisons ont été
évacuées avec les moyens du bord
des centaines de pompiers de gendarmes
ont été mobilisés avec des renforts de
la sécurité civile s'est montré très
vite très vite très très très très vite
on laisse pas ce que quoi un quart
d'heure
c'était incroyable on est sorti par la
fenêtre et on a nagé jusqu'à chez les
voisins hélas tous les meubles
flottaient les deux communes les plus
touchées sont celles de la faute-sur-mer
et de l'aiguillon-sur-mer où la digue a
cédé le problème de la que la mer monte
d'un mètre
non rien de turcotte mais il ya un
phénomène
justement vous expliquer imaginez vous
un mètre devant vous qui s'avance et
qui ravagent tout vision d'horreur les
vents violents se sont conjugués à une
marée de fort coefficient
personne n'imaginait un tel déluge on
n'a jamais vu ça à quoi on se croirait
dans un film c'est horrible on n'a pas
vu le truc venerquois cc ont été
tellement vite que l'on n'a rien que
faire on a appelé les pompiers mais ils
ont débordé de partout donc ce soir
rien n'est réglé chacun cherche encore
des nouvelles de ses proches
j'attends que ont soufflé par an je
comprends pas l'application ce matin
bonjour papa ça va ils sont bloqués dans
leurs normes enfer depuis 4 heures ce
matin ils sont pas secourus non cola je
suis très inquiète très inquiète parce
qu'on m'a dit que la halle à marées à
les remonter
donc ils ont pu électricité plus rien
sont plus de soixante dix ans les
secours ont encore reçu des renforts
il se prépare à passer une nuit
supplémentaire alors que s'annonce une
nouvelle grande marée et en direct de
l'aiguillon sur mer on retrouve karine
comazzi bon soeur karine alors vous êtes
sur l'une des deux communes les plus
touchées par la tempête
vous avez suivi les pompiers dans leur
travail on commence j'ai l'impression a
réalisé depuis quelques heures l'ampleur
de la catastrophe tout à fait marrer peu
avant 20 heures le bilan officiel de la
préfecture était de 25 morts jeudi
officielle parce que ce sont le nombre
de corps c'est le nombre de corps qui
sont disposés au funérarium de
l'aiguillon où je me trouve m'en fait le
bilan risque d'être beaucoup plus lourd
nous nous sommes rendus sur la commune
voisine de la faute sur mer où nous
avons suivi le travail des plongeurs
sauveteurs des hommes qui nous ont
confié officieusement avoir sorti près
de 40 corps sans vie
nous les avons suivis dans leur
embarcation dans ce lotissement dans un
calme pesant sur certaines maisons une
croix ou le signe vue qui signifie que
les pompiers étaient passés par ces
maisons sur d'autres maisons des tuiles
arrachées qui signifie que les gens
comme et de la maison vendéenne non pas
d'étagé les gens ont essayé de s'enfuir
par le toit
parfois ils ont attendu des heures dans
le froid un hélitreuillage ou une
embarcation qui venaient les sauver donc
ce soir la grande difficulté ce sont ces
maisons pour les sauveteurs
où les volets sont formés ils ne savent
pas s'il s'agit de résidences
secondaires inhabitée ou de gens qui
seraient terrés dans leurs maisons
ce soir les recherches ont cessé et va
commencer un sinistre travail le
décompte le décompte des personnes
heureusement sauvé le décompte des
disparus et le décompte malheureusement
des personnes décédées on devrait
connaître avec plus de précision dès
demain matin
un bilan qui s'annonce déjà très lourd
merci beaucoup aux karine pour ces
précisions la tempête xynthia a aussi
frappé fort la nuit dernière en
charente-maritime causant la mort de
plusieurs personnes et d'importants
dégâts
la rochelle a été particulièrement
touchée sur place anne billets et paix à
l'inde arrivant ils n'ont que leurs bras
pour évacuer cette femme âgée après la
tempête ou le quartier et inondées et
les pompiers sont débordés alors on
s'aide entre voisins par monsieur en
fait hors de l'eau en show vient après
moi je suis retourné chez moi c'est vers
eux que faute à quelques kilomètres on
emploie les grands moyens pour évacuer
les campings les résidents été surpris
en plein sommeil par la montée des eaux
car au milieu de la nuit la mer
déchaînée est passé par dessus les
digues et malgré le danger certains
promeneurs prennent tous les risques
le port de la rochelle disparaît sous
les flots les bateaux se retrouve au
dessus des voitures et les piétons dans
l'eau
en fait est très dangereuse qu'on a
surtout peur des bouches d'égout rhin
s'est pas trop en marche pour va c'est
assez inquiétant jamais vu d'aussi haute
n'a jamais bu l'eau atteigne ce niveau
là et pourtant là aussi des
automobilistes s'aventure dans l'eau
malgré les conseils de prudence
ils sont rapidement prises au piège
certains parviennent à se dégager
d'autres tentent en vain de récupérer
leur véhicule
pour l'instant voilà ça peu la panique
la sur le corps nous ont rentré de
mission et on nous a pris pour des
personnes qui étaient bloqués dans leur
véhicule ouais donc c'est un peu tout le
monde est débordé d'un à la lumière du
jour on constate les dégâts parfois
considérables cet hôtel a tout perdu
on avait donc des vagues de plus d'un
mètre cinquante donc sur la route c'est
énorme ça détruites il a tout détruit
tu te tous les effets personnels ont
fait le tour en fin de compte de l'hôtel
ils sont revenus par une autre entrée
donc c'est vraiment apocalyptique en
charente maritime
six personnes ont péri dans la tempête
et deux autres sont portées disparues
un bilan peut-être encore provisoire
nous allons rejoindre maintenant le
centre de gestion de crise à asnières on
retrouve le commandant samuel bernès
bonsoir monsieur alors vous êtes porte
parole de la sécurité civile
on avance ce soir un bilan de 45 morts
certes on l'a entendu 29 victimes en
vendée victimes de la rupture d'une
digue
mais que dire des autres ont-ils été
victimes de leur imprudence je ne crois
pas qu'on pût qu'on puisse dire qu'ils
aient été victimes de leurs un
pré-lancement dans les autres
départements il ya eu également des
personnes qui ont été surpris pas
surprises par les eaux il y a eu des
gens qui ont été intoxiquées au monoxyde
de carbone alors justement on peut on
peut profiter de cette antenne pour
spécifier que lorsqu'il ya des coupures
électriques et conduit utilisent des
groupes électrogènes et bien il faut
faire attention aux émanations de
monoxyde de carbone c'est un gaz qui est
incolore inodore et donc il faut il faut
il faut être prudent dans l'utilisation
ces groupes électrogènes alors de
l'imprudence en général non je pense que
malheureusement les autres victimes dans
les autres départements
ben peut-être était au mauvais moment au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
notamment les gens qui ont reçu les
branches d'arbres les arbres ou
des matériaux qui ont été emportées par
le vent voilà des gens qui étaient
malheureusement au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
outre de ne pas utiliser des groupes
électrogènes vous le mentionnez ai rien
à l'instant quel autre consigne donnée
vous ce soir
écoutez c'est d'abord c'est pas
forcément ne pas utiliser les groupes
électrogènes mais il faut être prudent
dans l'utilisation de ces matériels qui
s'ils ne sont pas en bon état de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont
pas été entretenues peuvent générer des
émanations de monoxyde de carbone
maintenant les conseils qu'on peut
donner à la population est bien bien sûr
ça dépend des départements là le vent
s'est dissipé il n'y a plus de vent sur
sur la france donc les gens peuvent
rv à camphin vaquer à leurs occupations
maintenant les gens qui sont
effectivement les deux départements les
plus touchés que ce soit la charente
maritime où la vendée eh bien il faut
évidemment et c'est essayer de
collaboration est sûre avec les secours
de ceux de se sortir de ces de ces
situations extrêmement dramatique
dernière question monsieur bernès vous
dit le vent s'est calmé ce soir ça veut
dire que le danger est définitivement
écartée alors
météo france avait annoncé à 17h qu'il
n'y avait plus de vigilance orange vend
sur l'ensemble de la france
il y a encore les départements de
bretagne qui sont en vigilance crues et
inondations
donc voilà c'est en ce qui concerne la
tempête je pense que la tempête eric
m'en passer d'après d'après
effectivement les données de météo
france
merci beaucoup monsieur bernès pour ces
précisions et justement à certains
endroits la tempête allié au marée haute
a provoqué d'importantes inondations
certains villages sinistrés sont coupés
du monde plus d'eau ni d'électricité et
les routes impraticables reportage à
loix en ré antoine gaveau bernard
bonnaroo aujourd'hui les pompiers sont
les seuls à pouvoir emprunter cette
route ou ce qu'il en reste
sur l'île de ré la tempête a fait lâcher
de digues
la mère a envahi la terre et couper
certains habitants du reste du monde
alors voyez une voiture alors qu'il
votait côté de l'arrière elles sont
montées dans plusieurs vagues géantes
cette nuit et une partie du petit
village de loi est engloutie moi j'ai
jamais vu ça de toute façon même mon
père kaka 81 7 ans donc il a dit que non
ils avaient vu venir
un peu plus loin mais jamais jusqu'ici
dégâts matériels et catastrophe
économique pour les éleveurs d'huitres
nombreux sur l'île
j'ai pu cabanes ostréicoles tout mon
matériel est sous l'eau est bon mais pas
qu'on n'a pas pu aller voir mes sept au
paquebot et bombe à la wii plus
travailler non la série gagne là je
crois que je vais arrêter complètement
parce que c'est le moral n'y est plus du
tout là et les lectrices plus
d'électricité plus d'eau non plus les
habitants attendent la décrue et
s'organise avec les moyens du bord
débrouille comme on peut en avoir a pas
d'électricité on a on a des réserves
mais nos congélateurs forcément ils vont
on va aviser pour faire un don en
juillet pour pour se chauffer et puis
voilà sur l'île de ré on annonce à
nouveau des marais importante pour les
prochains jours cet isolement pourrait
donc durer toute la semaine
d'autant que ce scénario a été le même
un peu partout la tempête a balayé la
france du sud-ouest au nord-est en ville
en montagne ou sur le littoral on a pu
que constater les dégâts jean-françois
fierais fuir la tempête comme on le peut
en chaussures de ville quelques affaires
sous le bras la voiture roule encore
pour cette famille c'est une aubaine
mais à guingamp tout le monde n'a pas eu
cette chance jusqu'à un mètre d'eau dans
le centre de la ville en quelques
minutes
vers les 8 heures des gens ça commençait
à monter j'ai jamais eue s'est enchanté
depuis chassant l'autre à tort les
habitudes si jamais le quartier entier à
pied ce soir aucun décès n'a été
annoncée en bretagne mais les dégâts
sont importants mort les a été inondée à
yffiniac près de saint brieuc 15 cm dont
suffit à isoler des quartiers entiers
près de cherbourg dans la manche la mer
est entré dans les terres
heureusement les digues ici ont tenu
autre image à saint nazaire où cette
fois ce sont des rivières et des petits
cours d'eau qui ont débordé soulevant
les bateaux et obligeant les habitants à
déblayer leur maison il ya eu des
voitures emportées tout donc ça a été
assez fort pas de pluie mais beaucoup de
vent dans les pyrénées à bagnères de
luchon des rafales jusqu'à 150
kilomètres par heure les cèdres
centenaires sont tombés comme des jeunes
pousses un homme de 36 ans a été tuée en
altitude les voitures de ce parking ont
été projetés les unes contre les autres
pour les amateurs de sports d'hiver les
vacances sont terminées
j'ai vu depuis couloir mais puis l'eau
ne s'effondre et est tombés sur les
maisons j'ai vu leur la cavale du ski se
soit totalement il reste plus rien donc
j'ai vu que c'était très très sérieux
dehors en ile-de-france les vans ou fait
bien moins fort suffisamment tout de
même pour faire s'écrouler ce sapin sur
cette maison l'étagé dévastée
heureusement les locataires étaient
absents ce matin
un autre problème se pose dorénavant il
faut réparer le réseau électrique 2700
agences ont mobilisé des renforts y
compris de l'étranger sont attendus pour
demain
cinq cent mille foyers sont toujours
privés de courant
ce soir xynthia d'être mythiquement
quitter la france mais laisse derrière
elle des plaies qu'il faudra bien
réussir à penser et pour ce faire une
réunion de crise a été convoqué à
matignon cet après midi autour de
françois fillon 1 millions d'euros
d'aidé d'urgence va être débloqué on
propose d'écouter le premier ministre
c'est donc une catastrophe nationale et
mes premières pensées vont vers les
victimes et vers leurs familles
auxquelles je veux présenter les
condoléances
gouvernement et de la nation maintenant
la priorité c'est de mettre en sécurité
toutes les personnes sans abri toutes
les personnes qui sont encore menacées
par la montée des eaux
l'arrêté où les arrêtés de catastrophe
naturelle seront publiés dans les 48
heures enfin le gouvernement va avec les
collectivités locales
méd sur pied sans tarder un plan
exceptionnel de reconstruction et de
renforcement des digues à ce que l'on
pouvait dire ce soir donc après
vingt-quatre heures après cette tempête
qui a frappé la france qui se déplace
maintenant vers l'allemagne et qui
aurait fait chez nous au moins au total
à 45 morts et puis au chili lé
tremblement de terre a fait lui plus de
700 morts et quelques deux millions de
sinistrés la région de l'épicentre du
séisme à 500 km au sud de santiago est
totalement dévastée la présidente
michelle bachelet annonce ce soir la
distribution gratuite dans l'alimentaire
bernard le bras
la scène se déroule devant un
hypermarché les forces de police
arrivent en courant pour stopper les
pilleurs de l'unique magasin de cette
petite ville proche de l'épicentre
il faut lisser chilien sur ordre du
maire n'y vont pas par quatre chemins
autres scènes de pillage dans un
entrepôt de la grande distribution des
caméras sont présentes mais rien
n'arrête ces habitants qui piquent à
visage découvert en quête de
ravitaillement parmi eux il ya aussi des
casseurs organisé volant de
l'électroménager et non pas des produits
de première nécessité et la police
d'intervenir au canon à eau pour
disperser la foule à manger à manger dit
ce père de famille désespérée
nous avons besoin de nourriture pour les
enfants bien que la situation soit
dramatique par endroits la présidente
sortante du chili michelle bachelet n'a
pas demandé d'assistance internationale
se contentant de déclarer le centre du
chili en état de catastrophe
ce qui est vraiment le cas dans cet
immeuble de concepcion 60 à 100
personnes seraient bloquées dans les
décombres avec de petits moyens et leur
grande échelle les pompiers locaux
tentent de les libérer et il y a pire
situation encore dans les petites villes
de la côte pacifique talcahuano ici mais
aussi il y au chaos constitucion ont
connu un véritable raz-de-marée après le
séisme
déplaçant les bateaux dans les rues
ravageant les maisons on parle ici de
350 morts sur cette colline femmes et
enfants se sont réfugiés
je n'ai plus rien a dit cette mère de
famille que ce sujet sur moi plus au
nord dans la capitale de multiples
répliques ont poussé les habitants à
passer la nuit dehors avec leur
téléviseur
santiago il peut toucher mais nombre
d'infrastructures sont détruites ou
fermées comme l'aéroport et de puissance
et vos du chili on retrouve notre
confrère de france 3 samuel etienne
bonsoir samuel alors y at il une
d'autres répliques du séisme depuis 24
heures on son mari nous sommes là
santiago dans le sud est de la capitale
devant l'un des nombreux immeubles qui
se sont effondrés samedi
la terre continue de trembler marie des
dizaines de répliques chaque jour comme
celle assez violente qui a réveillé les
habitants de santiago ce matin au delà
de 6 sur l'échelle de richter et ce sont
des répliques qui complique le travail
des sauveteurs notamment au sud dans la
ville de conception une centaine de
personnes seraient toujours coincées
sous les décombres d'un immeuble de 14
étages alors ça mal comment s'organise
et les sinistrés et les secours santiago
est toujours une ville morte et habitent
tous les magasins sont fermés
communication très difficile certains
quartiers sont toujours privés
d'électricité mais c'est toujours dans
cette ville cette région de concepcion
dont je vous parlais où les conditions
de vie sont les plus difficiles il ya
des dizaines de milliers voire des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont sans abri et les policiers ont
commencé à intervenir les carabineros
pour empêcher des pillages des gens qui
pillent les magasins et bien tout
simplement pour se nourrir dernière
question samuel comment on peut
expliquer qu'un séisme de magnitude de
8,8 façon beaucoup beaucoup moins de
victimes qu'en haïti deux raisons mari
d'abord la terre ne cesse de trembler au
chili un handicap santiago la terre
tremble 500 fois par an et puis au fil
des années et bien des normes
antisismiques de plus en plus strictes
ont été mises en place tout simplement
une deuxième raison peut-être la plus
importante
contrairement à haïti l'épicentre du
séisme ici au chili était situé dans une
zone quasi désertique
il aurait suffi que cet épisode soit un
tout petit peu plus au nord-est et le
bilan mari aurait été beaucoup beaucoup
plus lourd
merci beaucoup samuel etienne donc
depuis
santiago du chili pour cet entretien
réalisé quelques minutes avant le
journal en campagne comme à la campagne
le salon de l'agriculture est chaque
année très prisé des politiques aussi
françois bayrou
y à t'il passé son dimanche le président
du modem a déclaré que les problèmes des
agriculteurs le toucher profondément et
vous cécile duflot mon soir vous êtes
secrétaire nationale des verts vous
allez aller au salon de l'agriculture
cette semaine oui j'y vais avec deux
autres têtes de liste philippe meirieu
qui était de liste en rhône-alpes et
françois dufour qui est tête de liste
europe écologie en basse normandie et
qui est paysan lui-même alors on va
revenir sur la campagne des régionales
dans un instant mais d'abord je vous
réponds qu'on revienne un instant sur
les violentes intempéries de ces 24
heures on l'a on l'a dit il ya quelques
minutes
le gouvernement débloque un million
d'euros date d'urgence c'est suffisant
d'abord c'est vrai qu'il faut penser aux
victimes et je pense que c'est soirée
très très difficile puisqu'il ya aussi
des gens qui sont aujourd'hui disparus
dont il ya vraiment une situation très
difficile sur les annonces c'est une
évidence une nécessité l'ensemble de la
solidarité nationale doit s'opérer
simplement il faut se souvenir qu'il ya
un an il ya une tempête dans les landes
les mêmes annonces qui n'ont pas été
suivies d'effet donc il faut vraiment
que ce soit pas seulement un effet de
communication mais bien que ce soit du
soutien dans la durée à tous ceux qui en
auront besoin
alors on va parler de vous maintenant et
de votre campagne pour ces régionales
2010 2010 tête de liste europe écologie
en ile-de-france donc les scrutins 14 et
21 mars
quel est votre objectif c'est faire
aussi bien aux européennes non c'est
faire mieux enfin l'objectif ne peut
être que faire mieux pourquoi pas parce
que on aurait la grosse tête mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment il nous
faut sortir du statut pour le seul vrai
risque aujourd'hui en politique c'est le
statu quo et europe écologie ça
insuffler de la vie dans la vitalité
démocratique c'est indispensable de
mettre en oeuvre des solutions nouvelles
on se bat pour répondre écologiquement à
la crise mais aussi pour créer des
emplois durables et non délocalisables
dans les régions donc on l on veut
vraiment agir voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
est candidat enfin vous vous battez
aussi et surtout contre le parti
socialiste vous êtes pourtant loin
derrière c'est réaliste faire plus qu
aux européennes rappelez-nous le score
16 % des autobus mais oui non c'est pas
on se bat pas contre le parti socialiste
du tout on se bat pour faire vivre la
démocratie et surtout pour apporter des
nouvelles solutions
on est quand même dans une situation
aujourd'hui où on est à deux semaines de
l'élite
sion tout juste et le débat pour
l'instant ça s'est résumé à élire des
ministres ou réélire des présidents
sortants est vraiment ce qui est
essentiel c'est de parler du projet de
savoir qu'est ce qu'on va faire en
matière de logement qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour lutter contre la précarité
énergétique
qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière
d'agriculture et comment on essaye
d'inventer des nouvelles solutions et je
pense que pour ça il faut faire vivre un
peu la démocratie dans ce pays
essayer de renouveler les solutions et
c'est ce que fait europe écologie dans
toutes les régions et renouveler le
paysage politique
peut-être un peu ça va avec et c'est pas
agressif que le dire c'est même plutôt
pacifique c'est juste qu'un moment quand
on est dans une situation comme celle
qu'on connaît il ya aujourd'hui 4
millions de personnes qui sont soit au
chômage soit en situation de précarité
professionnelle avec des contrats de
quelques heures et qu'on a quand même
épuisés les vieilles solutions se dit
qu'il faut inventer et qu'il faut
trouver des emplois durables et non
délocalisables et pour ça vous affirmer
pouvoir jouer les trouble fête et créer
les conditions de triangulaire dans
plusieurs régions à quelles conditions
vous vous rallierez au parti socialiste
non non on n'est pas du tout dans une
logique agressive ou dans une logique
tactique
au contraire on veut construire mais
construire des véritables solutions d
vrai projet politique mais si c'est le
cas et donc le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
que c'est des présidents socialistes qui
sont un peu méprisant voire très sûrs
d'eux et un peu hégémoniques et nous on
n'est pas dans cette logique là on dit
que si on veut qu' on est candidat si on
veut être élu c'est pour faire bouger
les choses c'est pas juste pour prendre
des postes ou pas juste pour rire les
trois accessions quelles seraient les
conditions du ralliement s'il y a des
triangulaires la région poitou charentes
par exemple est une région ce serait de
la responsabilité si on est dans cette
situation ce sera de la responsabilité
des socialistes c'est eux qui ont rendu
public pour certains d'entre eux leur
volonté de ne pas faire d'accord avec
europe écologie nous on veut apporter
ses solutions apporter du travail de
l'énergie je vous ai dit revivifier la
vie politique très tranquillement et si
les conditions d'un accord sont
possibles elles le seront mais il
faudrait que ce soit dans toutes les
régions
on pourra pas acheter europe écologie
parti paquet on n'est pas dans cette
logique on est vraiment dans la logique
de la vie démocratique
merci beaucoup cécile duflot d'avoir
répondu aux questions du 20 heures de
france 2 il est 20 heures 22 à suivre
dans votre journal la fin d'un avantage
demain les règles de paiement par titre
restaurant se durcissent dans les
grandes surfaces
vancouver c'est fini la nuit prochaine
11 médailles françaises c'est mieux qu'à
turin en 2006 retour sur les plus belles
images de ces jeux olymp
et puis la 35e cérémonie des césar le
sacre d'un film un prophète et le sacre
d'un homme tahar rahim meilleur espoir
meilleure acteur il est notre invité
mais d'abord à partir de demain il sera
impossible de payer les courses de la
semaine avec des titres restaurant et
oui cette pratique illégale mais tolérée
dans les supermarchés irrité les
restaurateurs qui dénonçait une
concurrence déloyale
ils ont donc obtenu gain de cause romain
boutilly julien duperré à la location
c'est l'histoire d'un bout de papier
avec lequel certains avaient pris des
libertés
prévu à l'origine pour payer son
déjeuner le ticket restaurant s'est
transformé depuis quelques années en
moyen de paiement comme un autre capable
même d'arrondir les fins de mois avec le
maroc n'est pas autorisée mais je le
fais on n'a pas forcément envie de
manger tous les midis pour 8 euros 50
ont forcément à la fin du mois il en
reste du coup j'ai soldes pour faire les
courses
dix mois une pratique interdite que les
distributeurs ont longtemps tolérée
concurrence déloyale ont dénoncé les
restaurateurs du coup au 1er mars
la règle se durcit seuls les produits à
consommer immédiatement seront acceptées
c'est à dire sandwichs plats cuisinés
surgelés conserve salade
dans la limite de deux tickets par
client et quart à ceux qui ne joueront
pas le jeu
en cas d'infraction l'enseigne se verra
tout simplement retiré le droit
d'accepter les titres restaurant nous
nous appliquons cette règle parce que ce
nous a été demandé par l'organisation
des tickets restaurant on se
correspondent à la logique que les
tickets restaurants soient utilisés pour
de l'alimentation restaurant qui
pourrait également faire son entrée sur
les étals des marchés depuis juillet
dernier les trois millions de
bénéficiaires ont légalement le droit de
payer ainsi leurs fruits et légumes mais
le décret n'est pas encore publiée la
ministre de l'économie donnera son feu
vert dans les jours qui viennent
voilà c'est fini après quinze jours de
folie olympiques les jeux s'achève la
nuit prochaine tragédie déception faurie
grands ratés surprise christophe
duchiron revient pour nous sur les
moments les plus forts
le 12 février dernier les lumières
électriques et les perles de pluie
faisait de vancouver une ville en
suspension
en effet au moment de la cérémonie
d'ouverture le temps s'est suspendu une
minute d'un pur silence en hommage au
lugeur venus de géorgie
moreau jeu à 21 ans le matin à
l'entraînement
malgré la flamme olympique et la
pyrotechnie ambiante les jeux débuté
dans une atmosphère crépusculaire
à la lumière du sport la norvégienne
marit bjoergen restera comme l'étoile la
plus brillante et la plus titrée des
jeux 5 médailles en ski de fond dont 3
en or
chez l'oise et rigolarde mademoiselle
wang fut la reine sur le petit anneau de
vitesse du short track
elle n'a pas sa langue dans sa poche qui
les deux pieds dans le même patins elle
va repartir en chine avec trois
médailles d'or autour du coeur
france ô à ski le suisse simon ammann 55
kg ressemble un petit oiseau avec des
plume d'or
deux titres olympiques
du point de vue artistique le plus beau
des feux d'artifice a eu lieu à la
patinoire
à 19 ans seulement la coréenne kim yu na
mi temps de bloquer dans son patinage
qu'elle a subis mais un moment de sport
en instant de grâce médaille d'or haut
la main et larme à l'oeil
durant deux semaines qu'ils soient
spectateurs ou athlètes de haut niveau
les canadiens ont mis le feu aux jeux
d'hiver qui furent qu'une fête populaire
est un succès sportif
avant la finale masculine de hockey sur
glace ce soir le canada totalise déjà
treize médailles d'or ce qui le place en
tête définitivement au classement des
nations
les canadiens ne sont pas prêts
d'oublier les jeux de vancouver miller
patineuse joannie rochette qui avait
tenu à patiner coûte que coûte deux
jours après le décès de sa mère
terrassée par une crise cardiaque
elle obtiendra une médaille de bronze il
affective ovation du public
les canadiens n'oublieront pas de sitôt
17 jours de compétition d'exploit de
rires de larmes de déception
toutes les couleurs de l'émotion les
césar ont couronné une reine et un
prophète il y avait là aussi toutes les
couleurs de l'émotion avec un cinquième
trophée pour son rôle dans la journée de
la jupe isabelle adjani et de venir sur
la comédienne la plus césarisé de
l'histoire quant à un prophète pas moins
de neuf césars pour le film de jacques
audiard dont un doublé inédit pour le
jeune tahar rahim
pascal deschamps antoine noël il est une
heure du matin coulisses est un vrai
hymne qui n'en revient toujours pas
n'attendez pas
je m'attends soit on paie maintenant
c'était quand même le césar du meilleur
espoir masculin est attribué à tarime le
césar du meilleur acteur est attribué à
tarime deux césar pour un jeune acteur
quasi inconnue il ya dix mois
le pari réussi de jacques audiard tahar
rahim porte littéralement son film
pendant deux heures 35
tu vois bien longtemps sans protection
tiendrait il reçoit l'hommage de son
partenaire niels arestrup lui-même césar
du meilleur second rôle est une grande
chance d'avoir un partenaire comme tu as
rome
non seulement parce que c'est un acteur
fabuleux mais aussi parce que c'est un
homme extraordinaire un prophète succès
public et critique de l'année 2009
remportons qui neuf statuettes
une soirée marquée aussi par l'émotion
d'une star la mère a été très à
l'honneur ce soir
et voilà je gère brasse là même où
qu'elles se trouvent dans la journée de
la jupe film à petit budget qu'elles
portent à bout de bras
elle est un professeur de lettres en
butte au machisme de ses élèves il y en
aura eu malgré tout un peu pour tout le
monde
emmanuelle devos meilleur second rôle
pour à l'origine mélanie thierry
meilleur espoir pour le dernier pour la
route deux césar pour le concert 1 pour
mademoiselle chambon un palmarès
équilibré malgré un absent
welcome
dans une semaine jour pour jour tahar
rahim et jacques audiard s'apprêterait à
fouler le tapis rouge du kodak theater
avec à la clé peut-être un oscar tarime
montfort merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et bravo bravo cette fois vous allez
aller à hollywood
car oui les semaines deux césar c'est
lourd à porter pour un seul homme pour
un seul jeune homme oui c est idiot et
le poids de quoi alors c'est un jeu je
sais pas c'est quand même assez inouïe
de se retrouver comme ça déjà d'être
nominé pour moi aux côtés du comédien
comme cluzel lindon attal c'était juste
incroyable moi je m'en contente est
parfaitement j'étais juste peut-être
qu'ils y penser la même chose de vous
les aurez tort pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
ils ont quand même ils ont quand même
apporter beaucoup à l'histoire du cinéma
français à travers beaucoup de grands
films de deux grands rôles etc
moi j'en ai fait qu'un oui mais quel
film je suis très content est ce que le
deuxième césar quand vous avez eu
meilleur espoir en début de cérémonie
quand on vous appelle la deuxième fois
que ça fait autant plaisir que le
premier ou un peu moins le premier m'a
fait extrêmement plaisir parce que je
j'espère la voir le deuxième je m'y
attendais pas du tout donc je ne sais
pas du tout si je sais pas c'était un
plaisir c'est un mélange de plein de
choses mon coach est extrêmement choquée
sur le coup je m'y attendais pas je me
suis dit waouh qu'est ce qui se passe
vous pensez à quoi et à qui à ce moment
là au moment d'entonner votre nom et
vous fait le trajet jusqu'à jusqu'à la
scène
je ne sais pas c'est quand on va sur un
prix c'est un instant c'est assez
spécial
c'est comme une distorsion du temps
c'est pas si cécile 10 secondes valent
dix secondes ou 10 minutes 10 minutes
j'espère on est vraiment moi j'étais
entre deux entre deux de deux mondes etc
c'est entre deux qu'on ressent donc je
suis face à jacques ensuite je vois les
autres joie le bonheur sur le visage des
autres alors je vais les voir sur scène
alors vous avez 28 ans et sa cinq ans de
métier en tout cas vous tourner depuis
cinq ans vous avez fait je crois des
études de cinéma
c'est vrai que c'est votre premier grand
film les téléspectateurs de télévision
vous ont découvert aussi dans une très
bonne série qui s'appelle la commune
qu'est ce que vous avez appris en
travaillant avec jacques audiard et avec
niels arestrup on a senti hier soir
qu'il ya quelque chose de très fort
entre vous deux ou trois mois oui j'ai
quasiment tout appris sur le plan
professionnel j'ai appris énormément de
choses je ne pourrais pas en parler
parce qu'on serait là demain matin mais
ouais j'ai quasiment tout appris sur
plan professionnel et sur le plan humain
j'en ai appris encore plus je me suis
rendu compte que que les plus grands
sont sont très très très très humble et
que
youtube qui sont accessibles aussi avec
malgré par exemple pour nils toustou
nils qu'il est à travers cette carrière
qui fait qu'il a fait il ne me
conseillait pas non pas pour un pour ne
pas me conseillez mais juste parce que
par rapport à son humilité
c'est certainement le meilleur conseil
qu'il pouvait vous donnait d'ailleurs
sans le vouloir ils m'ont envoyé au
charbon et c'est ce qui va mieux
vous êtes certainement maintenant très
courtisé d'un beau qu'elles sont quels
sont vos projets à venir dans les mois
qui viennent ben là je démarre un
tournage avec lou ye un réalisateur
chinois qui a réalisé interdit de
tourner dans son pays exactement
ouais donc et ensuite je démarrerai un
film avec ismaël ferroukhi qui aurait
fait le grand voyage on le les vues
pendant que vous regardiez le reportage
c'est drôle vous avez comme souvent les
acteurs et des actrices vous avez un peu
de mal à vous voir à la télévision plus
de mal vous me disiez que de vous
regarder au cinéma pourquoi nation parce
que c'était pas plus de mal mais c'est
plus surprenant parce que tout
simplement je ne jouais pas je n'étais
pas dans un rôle quoi c'est et comme je
disais on est on est d'un milliard de
choses nous traverse à ce moment là et
de voir ça sur mon visage
c'est bizarre bravo merci et bravo merci
beaucoup d'avoir à répondre à nos
questions je précise que e-label adjani
aurait dû être présente ce soir dans ce
journal à vos côtés en était ravi
d'ailleurs malheureusement elle a été
obligée d'annuler pour des raisons
personnelles voilà mais nous l'avions
annoncé dans le journal de 13h merci
beaucoup et bonne chance encore si
beaucoup cinéma encore avec le
box-office comme chaque semaine voici le
meilleur démarrage de cette semaine du
film le premier jour de leur sortie
excellent premier jour pour le scorsese
shutter island avec leonardo dicaprio et
puis vient derrière une comédie
française coursier avec michaël youn
voilà avant de refermer journal on va
revenir sur cette catastrophe nationale
la tempête de ces dernières 24 heures a
fait au moins 45 morts deux départements
ont été particulièrement touché la
charente maritime et la vendée où la
rupture d'une digue a surpris une partie
de la population dans son sommeil
faisant 25 victimes
hakim abdel khaleq
une catastrophe nationale selon le
gouvernement il n'a pas fallu une heure
pour qu'en vendée des centaines de
maisons soit inondées jusqu'au toit
cette nuit au coeur de la tempête cette
digue aaron plus piéger en contre bas
des milliers de riverains sur les
communes de l'aiguillon et de la faute
sur mer
laurent très par l'ex net par les portes
c'est qu'on sait très vite très vite
très très très très vite
en l'espace de quoi un quart d'heure au
petit matin les évacuations se
poursuivaient des centaines d'hommes
sont mobilisés notamment à la rochelle
la solidarité s'organise les voisins
aide les plus fragiles par monsieur
connaître hors de l'eau en show vient
après moi je suis retourné chez moi saut
vers eux dans le secteur près de 400
personnes sont ce soir sans abri elles
passeront la nuit dans cette école où le
ravitaillement en eau et en nourriture a
été prévu ce soir le bilan est encore
provisoire entre 45 et 50 morts
mais d'autres corps pourraient être
découverts dans des maisons encore
inondées et j'ajoute que nicolas sarkozy
se rendra dans ces deux départements la
charente maritime et la vendée
dès demain voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal tout de suite la météo tania
young et puis juste après cinéma un très
beau film ce qui reste avec emmanuelle
devos et vincent lindon l'information
demain c'est dès 6h30 sur france 2
télématin 13 heures elise lucet 20h
david pujadas excellente soirée sur
france 2 merci de votre attention
l'info en continu s'est tassée sur
france 2 pourrait faire